"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" is
practically bursting with Spider-People,
and most of them actually have
significant origins in the comic
books. Wondering what those origins are?
We're here to explain. Spoilers Ahead!
"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" opens with
Earth-65's Spider-Woman, Gwen Stacy, giving the
audience a glimpse of her life after the events of
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse." We learn that
this version of Spider-Gwen has an origin story
similar to her comic book counterpart's, which
occurred in "Edge of Spider-Verse" issue 2. After
receiving powers from the bite of an irradiated
spider, she establishes a secret identity and
fights crime as a vigilante. Her best friend,
Peter Parker, transforms himself into the Lizard,
accidentally dying in their ensuing battle. Gwen's
father, police officer George Stacy, mistakenly
assumes that Spider-Woman murdered the boy.
Frightened and uncertain about her relationships
and future, she jumps at the chance to join
the Spider Society. This sprawling team of
spider-powered superheroes from different Earths
have banded together under Earth-928's Miguel
O'Hara to prevent the fabric of the multiverse
from being destroyed by dimension-hopping
anomalies. Along the way, she also discovers
the shocking truth about her only other friend,
Miles Morales, the Spider-Man of Earth-1610,
and why he can never join the Society. However,
going against the group's directives, she catches
up with Miles during a mission. It's an impulsive
choice that leads to disastrous consequences.
Gwen eventually finds herself
kicked out of the Society,
as Miles is stranded on a hostile, unfamiliar
Earth. However, the drummer who never belonged
decides to form her own "band" of old and new
Spider-friends to locate and rescue Miles.
The protagonist of the "Spider-Verse"
trilogy, Miles Morales is the sole
Spider-Man of Earth-1610 and operates in
Brooklyn. Over a year has passed since
the events of "Into the Spider-Verse,"
with Miles fully embracing his role as
his city's super-powered protector, complete
with a new costume that he designed himself.
"My name is Miles Morales. I'm
Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man."
He crosses paths with the Spot,
an apparent joke of a villain who
rapidly transforms into a terrifying
threat over the course of the film.
Miles learns about the existence of the Spider
Society following an unexpected visit from his
friend, Earth-65's Gwen Stacy who was secretly
sent to his Earth to monitor and detain the Spot.
Unbeknownst to her, Miles follows her through a
multiversal portal as she tracks down the villain.
There his actions nearly cause the destruction
of another Spider-Man's world. At the Society's
headquarters, he's denied membership to the group,
and discovers that he was the "original anomaly."
The spider that bit him was from Earth-42 and
was supposed to bite that world's Spider-person,
not him. Worse, the Society tries to
stop him from saving his father's life,
as the death of someone close to them is a
"canon event" that all Spiders must suffer.
Unwilling to accept this, Miles
makes a desperate bid to go home,
outmaneuvering the entire Society
in the process. However, he lands
on Earth-42 instead and is captured by
that world's Prowler: Miles Morales.
"Across the Spider-Verse" builds upon the
post-credits scene of its predecessor by
formally introducing Miguel O'Hara,
the Spider-Man of Earth-928. This
Spider-Man's dimension is set in the year
2099, and New York has transformed into the
technologically advanced city of Nueva
York. Aided by his holo-assistant Lyla,
Miguel forms the Spider Society, taking it
upon himself to maintain order across what
he calls the Arachno-Humanoid Poly-Multiverse.
Interestingly, he has some major beef with Miles
Morales. He blames Miles for being the very first
multiverse anomaly in "Into the Spider-Verse."
This version of Spider-Man 2099 is
barely recognizable from the original,
who first appeared in 1992's "Spider-Man 2099" #1.
The Miguel we see in "Across the Spider-Verse" is
an angry, tortured soul traumatized by his
past failings, completely devoid of a sense
of humor and prone to throwing objects in a
fit of rage. While not an outright villain,
he antagonizes Miles to a cruel degree. Aside
from revealing that Miles' father is fated to
die and prohibiting him from doing anything
about it, Miguel also tells the fledgling
superhero that he's nothing more than a mistake
and that he was never meant to be Spider-Man.
By the movie's end, Miguel and his strike
team are hunting Miles across the multiverse,
and it's clear that this "vampire
ninja" Spider-Man will stop at
nothing to keep the Spider-Verse "canon" intact.
The first new Spider-character introduced in
"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" is Jessica
Drew, the afroed arachnid-themed defender
of a yet-unrevealed Earth designation. A
tough-as-nails, tough-love-giving,
motorcycle-riding mother-to-be,
this web-slinging wonder fearlessly jumps
into battle. She instantly makes a strong
impression on Spider-Gwen, whom she invites to
the Society and takes under her wing as a protégé.
The original version of Jessica Drew was
introduced in 1977's "Marvel Spotlight" #32,
and she's been given a major revamp in many ways
for her silver screen animation debut. While not
much is known about the origin story of Jessica's
"Across the Spider-Verse" iteration, it is clear
that the Society's de facto leader, Miguel O'Hara,
trusts her considerably, to the point where she
basically acts as his second-in-command.
She is also critical of Peter B. Parker's
mentoring skills, hardly hesitating to point to
Miles as proof that he is a terrible teacher.
Initially, Jessica is strict towards Gwen,
emphasizing that the latter is her star student
and downright disapproving of her continued
association with Miles. She even does nothing when
Miguel expels Gwen from the Society and sends her
home. By the film's end, however, Jessica seems
proud that Gwen has taken the initiative to search
for Miles herself, without the Society's support.
During the sequence where the Spot first
explores the possibilities of his growing powers,
he takes a quick detour to Earth-13122, the
home of LEGO Spider-Man. This unique take on
the web-slinger was completely absent
in the promotional materials leading
up to the release of "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse." However,
his inclusion was revealed during the main
cast's interview with Fandango. Surprisingly,
LEGO Peter Parker plays a much bigger role
than just a "blink and you'll miss it" cameo.
After the black-and-white baddie shows up in the
LEGO universe and destroys a chunk of the Daily
Bugle building, we learn that LEGO Peter Parker
witnessed the whole event. Taking a quick break
from J. Jonah Jameson's hotheaded hassling, the
mild-mannered minifigure hides in a different
room and transforms into LEGO Spider-Man. He
activates his Spider Society device and reports
the incident to Miguel O'Hara, who thanks him
and calls him one of their best Spider-Men.
LEGO Spider-Man is a welcome addition
here and also represents a "full-circle"
moment of sorts. The first official
LEGO sets featuring the hero were
tie-ins for Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man,"
released in 2002. With that said,
the LEGO Spider-Man we see in "Across the
Spider-Verse" is based on the version that
came with the comic-inspired "Daily
Bugle" set, which came out in 2021.
When Gwen Stacy is ordered to find and arrest
the Spot in Earth-50101's Mumbattan, an invisible
Miles Morales secretly follows her. As a result,
Miles also meets Gwen's contact and Spider Society
teammate there: Pavitr Prabhakar, that Earth's
Spider-Man. Introduced as a lighthearted soul
who absolutely revels in being Spider-Man, Pavitr
gracefully swings through the city with his web
bangles, showing a natural gift for super heroics
despite being a superhero for just six months.
"Being Spider-Man is so easy. I fight a few bad
guys, quick break for a chai with my auntie…"
He is also quick to sense the romantic
tension between Miles and Gwen,
and doesn't hesitate to bring it
up multiple times, while sharply
poking fun at Western stereotypes of Indian
culture during their fight against the Spot.
Unfortunately, this encounter paves
the way for a demonstration of the
consequences of multiversal meddling.
When Miles prevents a "canon event" by
saving Earth-50101's Inspector Singh from
being crushed by debris, Pavitr's reality
begins to collapse. We then see the Spider
Society's multiverse repair team on the scene,
planting devices that were designed
to prevent dimensional incursions.
In the comics, the character first appeared
in 2005's "Spider-Man: India" #1. There,
he sports a costume that is much closer in
appearance to the classic Spider-Man suit,
but with white pants and red
pointed shoes. Additionally,
the comics version of Pavitr operates in
Mumbai rather than a made-up location.
Whenever applicable, "Across the
Spider-Verse" makes sure that each
Spider-character incorporates visual aspects of
their respective dimensions into their overall
aesthetic. There is no better example of this
than the Spider-Man of Earth-138, Hobie Brown,
the Spider-Punk. A literal walking
collage of newspapers and band posters,
the anarchic Spider-Punk cooly strums his
guitar in the heat of battle, bringing
electrifying energy wherever he goes while never
hesitating to give The Man the middle finger.
Hobie lends some much-needed assistance to
Spider-Gwen, Miles, and Pavitr Prabhakar
at a critical moment on Earth-50101, as
they try to stop the Spot from activating
Alchemax's super collider in that reality.
He also accompanies Miles and Gwen to the
Spider Society HQ on Earth-928, where it quickly
becomes clear that he and Miguel O'Hara mutually
dislike each other. In one sequence, Hobie is
thrilled when Peter B. Parker's daughter Mayday,
fills her diaper while Miguel is holding her,
saluting the child while calling the act "taking
a crap on the establishment." Crucially,
Hobie helps Miles escape from captivity,
taking advantage of the ensuing chaos
at the Spider Society HQ to quit.
Later on, his friendship with Gwen becomes a
massive boon when both Miles and Gwen go rogue:
The "Project Bootleg" dimension-hopping
device he leaves for her on Earth-65
enables Gwen to recruit her trusted
Spider-allies to join her splinter group.
The Spider-Mobile is one of the oddest yet most
iconic parts of Spider-Man's comic book history.
Built together by Spider-Man and his best bud, the
Human Torch, the Spider-Mobile made its first full
appearance in 1974's "Amazing Spider-Man" #130
but was rendered unusable roughly 30 issues later.
Still, it has been brought back repeatedly in the
books, as both a functional vehicle and a museum
display piece, much to the web slinger's
embarrassment. In recent years, however,
its most noteworthy comeback was in 2015's
"Amazing Spider-Man" Vol. 3 #12, not as a vehicle
for Spider-Man to ride, but as a legitimate,
sentient Spider-Man variation from Earth-53931.
This version of the Spider-Mobile, along with
the secret identity of "Peter Parkedcar," makes
an appearance in "Spider-Man: Across
the Spider-Verse." It is perhaps the
sheer ridiculousness of Parkedcar's existence
that earned it a few seconds in the spotlight:
The Spider-Mobile is one of the few
Spider Society members Miles gets
officially introduced to, complete with
its Earth designation in a caption box,
while he explores the facilities of the Spider
Society HQ with Spider-Gwen, Spider-Punk,
and Jessica Drew. Parkedcar also joins the rest
of the Society in trying to apprehend Miles,
but it humorously fails to cross the web
tightrope held by another Spider-variant.
One look at the Scarlet Spider in "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse" would be enough for
any comics fan to know that this version of
Ben Reilly embodies the essence of grim
and gritty 1990s comics, from heavily
inked head to toe. Unfortunately, fans who
were expecting a respectable interpretation
of the fan-favorite Spider-clone are
unlikely to find it in this iteration.
Hailing from Earth-94, a reference to
the character's first appearance as the
Scarlet Spider in 1994's "Web of Spider-Man"
#118, the Ben Reilly we meet in this movie
is a tongue-in-cheek caricature of '90s comic
book cliches. From his unnecessarily verbose
descriptions of otherwise mundane objects,
his obsession with muscles and hitting the
"perfect pose," and his penchant for whiny
introspection, it's a Herculean challenge to
take this character seriously, particularly
because he takes himself too seriously.
The Scarlet Spider joins Miguel O'Hara and
Jessica Drew during the film's third act as
they search for Miles Morales on Earth-1610.
Unfortunately, his peculiar mannerisms and
profound lack of awareness quickly become his
undoing. Spider-Gwen makes short work of him,
tricking him into getting sucked into
her bootleg portal while separating him
from his dimension-crossing device. At this
point, it's anyone's guess if he'll show up
in the next film, and if he'll be more than
just a walking stereotype played for laughs.
When Miles first steps into the Spider
Society HQ, he meets a mind-blowing array
of Spider-characters with different abilities.
Still, this doesn't stop the excited youth from
introducing himself as "Spider-Man" to the
cyberspace Spider-hero called Spider-Byte,
who sarcastically deadpans,
"Whoa, no way… All of us are."
In "Across the Spider-Verse," Margo's
digital avatar acts as the gatekeeper
of sorts for the Spider Society.
Operating from the control room,
one of Spider-Byte's responsibilities is to
send the multiverse-crossing supervillains
the Society detains back to their respective
dimensions. As the resident arachnid-themed
avenger of Earth-22191, this version of Margo
Kess could just as easily be another virtual
extension of her comic book counterpart, who
first appeared in 2018's "Vault of Spiders" #1.
After successfully eluding the entire Spider
Society, Miles uses his ability to turn
invisible to evade Margo's gaze and sneaks into
the teleporter in an attempt to send himself back
to Earth-1610. However, because the teleporter
selects where to send its passenger based on the
origin of their powers, it mistakenly sends Miles
to Earth-42, the home dimension of the spider that
bit him. Crucially, Margo gets an opportunity to
reboot the system and prevent Miles from escaping
but opts not to do anything. Instead, she lets
him beam out of their HQ. So it's no surprise when
she shows up as a member of Spider-Gwen's newly
formed rogue faction in the film's final scenes.
Of course, it wouldn't be a proper
"Spider-Verse" movie without everyone's
favorite easygoing Spider-sensei, Peter B. Parker.
"Watch this. He's gonna say,
'You've got twenty-four hours."
"You've got twenty-four hours."
This time around, it looks like the
old, tired Spider-Man of Earth-616,
or as Spider-Punk calls him, "Humbling Reality
Spider-Man," has managed to finally pick himself
up and get his act together. He has also
traded his homeless, dimension-displaced
get-up from "Into the Spider-Verse" for
a proper set of threads, specifically,
a pink bathrobe and baby harness. In other words,
the dadbod Spider-Man has become an actual dad.
Upon his return to his own dimension,
Peter reconciles with Mary Jane Watson.
Their rekindled love results in the
birth of their daughter, Mayday,
who has inherited her father's amazing
spider powers. Ever the devoted parent,
Peter made her a web-shooting bracelet. As it
turns out, Peter's adventure with Miles Morales in
the previous film helped him get over his fear of
becoming a parent. He even admits as much to his
protégé during their brief but heated conversation
after Miles breaks out of the Spider Society HQ.
After Miles escapes, Peter returns to
his homeworld, setting Mayday in her
crib and halfheartedly denying to MJ that he
brought their kid on another fight. However,
this quiet night at the Parker household
comes to an end when Spider-Gwen pops
up in Peter's backyard through Hobie's
dimension-hopping device. As expected,
Peter decides to join Gwen
in her search for Miles.
When the first trailer for "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse" was released,
eagle-eyed Spider-fans immediately spotted
a familiar, albeit largely forgotten,
version of the web slinger mixed in with the
rest of the Spider Society: the Peter Parker
of Earth-751263, otherwise known as Spider-Man
Unlimited from the eponymous 1999 cartoon.
This small detail got many fans excited, as it
pretty much confirmed the likelihood of other,
more popular animated Spider-Men showing
up in "Across the Spider-Verse" as well.
True enough, subsequent promotional materials
revealed that the Spider-Man of the fan-favorite
"Spectacular Spider-Man" animated series from
2008, designated as Earth-26496 is also part
of the movie. While Unlimited didn't really get to
do anything significant during the film's runtime,
Spectacular gets two moments to shine.
Aside from a scene during Miguel O'Hara's
Arachno-Humanoid Poly-Multiverse explainer
depicting Spectacular's version of the ASM-90
canon event, voice actor Josh Keaton
briefly reprises his role. He gets to
deliver a one-liner meant to dissuade Miles
from preventing Earth-1610's canon event:
the death of his father, the recently
promoted Captain Jeff Morales.
One not-so-surprising inclusion
is the Spider-Man from Earth-67,
the Spider-Man from the pointing meme. The '67
Spider-Man joins the Society in pursuing Miles,
bravely announcing his arrival
before demonstrating his signature
ineffectiveness by swinging way too
slow to catch the renegade Spider.
It's safe to say that one of the
biggest questions on everyone's minds
about "Across the Spider-Verse" was:
would Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield,
and Tom Holland be part of the movie? After all,
we recently witnessed the live-action Spider-trio
make cinematic history in 2021's "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," so it would make sense for them
to be in another multiverse-spanning
Spider-flick. The answer is…sort of.
Both Maguire, the Friendly Neighborhood
Spider-Man of Earth-96283= and Garfield,
the Amazing Spider-Man of Earth-120703 play
small roles in "Across the Spider-Verse."
Miguel explains to Miles that every Spider-Man
must go through a canon event that involves a
character close to the web slinger of
the universe dying in a tragic way.
During the explanation, a few seconds of the death
of Capt. George Stacy from 2012's "The Amazing
Spider-Man" is shown. Moments later, the death
of Uncle Ben, arguably the canon event of canon
events for most versions of Spider-Man, becomes
the focus of the discussion. In the background,
we see snippets of Maguire and Cliff Robertson's
Ben Parker, who dies in 2002's "Spider-Man."
Meanwhile, Holland's Spider-Man
doesn't appear at all, although
he does get mentioned in the first few
minutes of "Across the Spider-Verse."
"Don't even get me started on Doctor Strange
and the little nerd from Earth-199999."
While many of the members of the Spider
Society in "Across the Spider-Verse" can
easily be described as Spider-Man
variants based on their costumes,
there are a handful with distinct visual elements
that make them stand out from the Spider-crowd.
Undoubtedly, one of them is Max
Borne, the Spider-Man of 2211,
who hails from the comic book world of
Earth-9500. This futuristic Spider-Man
takes the arachnid aesthetic to a whole new
level. Aside from his multi-eyed helmet,
he also sports four red appendages protruding
from what looks like a metallic backpack.
In "Across the Spider-Verse," Spider-Man 2211
briefly steals the show near the beginning of
Miles Morales' extended chase sequence,
when the teenager hilariously clings to
Borne's crimson carapace in a feeble
attempt to hide from the rest of the
Society. This also causes the Society to
mistake Borne for Miles for a few seconds,
emphasizing how the group has become so large
that they don't even know one another's names.
Interestingly enough, Spider-Man 2211's first
appearance was in a comic book that featured two
different versions of the web slinger meeting: the
1995 one-shot "Spider-Man 2099 Meets Spider-Man"
#1. Similar to his role in this film, Spider-Man
2211's job in that comic is to help preserve the
integrity of the timeline. He appears in the
nick of time to save Peter Parker and Miguel
O'Hara from being erased from existence via
the "retcon bombs" of the Hobgoblin of 2211.
As part of the marketing efforts
for "Across the Spider-Verse," Sony
released a clip welcoming audiences
to the "Spider-Zoo." Indeed, there's
a mini-menagerie of Spider-powered animals who
somehow qualified for Spider Society membership.
Among the first we meet is Widow, nicknamed
"Spider-Horse," the trusty masked steed
of Patrick O'Hara, the cowboy Spider-Man
of Earth-31913. There's also Spider-Cat,
a character originally from 2011's "Spider-Island:
I Love New York City" #1, who spits up
a web-hairball in Miles Morales' face.
Spider-Monkey from the Marvel
Apes dimension also appears
a few times in the extended chase
sequence, though the spider-powered
simian's agility does little good in
helping the Society apprehend Miles.
The most attention-grabbing
Spider-creature here, however,
is Spider-Rex, a Tyrannosaurus rex in a Spider-Man
costume, complete with web-shooters around its
tiny wrists. A recent comics creation that
debuted in 2022's "Edge of Spider-Verse" #1,
Spider-Rex was originally a Pteranodon
simultaneously bitten by a T. rex and
smashed by a meteorite with alien spider
stowaways. A "Freaky Friday" situation ensues,
with the Pteranodon now inhabiting the T. rex's
body, inexplicably clad in a spider-themed suit.
"It CAN get weirder!"
Nicolas Cage told Screen Rant in January 2023
that Sony did not reach out to him to reprise
his role as Spider-Man Noir in "Into the
Spider-Verse." Neither Kimiko Glenn nor
John Mulaney, who played Peni Parker and
Spider-Ham, confirmed their participation,
quashing hopes for the secondary Spider-trio’s
return in "Across the Spider-Verse."
As it turns out, however, the multiversal
pals do pop up unexpectedly — and it looks
like they'll play even bigger roles in
the next film, "Beyond the Spider-Verse."
The first of the three to appear in
"Across the Spider-Verse" is Peni,
who is seen piloting an upgraded, more streamlined
version of her companion spider's robotic costume,
after the original was destroyed in the previous
movie's final battle. This new mechanical suit
closely resembles its comic book counterpart,
as seen in 2014's "Edge of Spider-Verse" #5.
As for Spider-Ham and Spider-Man Noir,
the two show up at the end of the film
as members of Spider-Gwen's splinter Spider-squad,
to help her outmaneuver Miguel O'Hara's
Spider Society and find Miles first.
Miguel O'Hara's Spider Society spans
the entirety of the Spider-Verse,
and features both existing characters and original
heroes created for "Across the Spider-Verse."
A good number of the Spider Society members
draw design inspiration from established
Spider-folks but aren't 100% accurate to
their multimedia counterparts. For example,
one character looks like Arachnido Jr.,
while a few are wearing different versions of
Earth-616 Spider-Man's various Spider-Armors.
One Society member resembles Spider-Man's brutal
clone, Spidercide; others draw inspiration from
characters like Ai Apaec and Julia
Carpenter's Spider-Woman. Some fans
even reportedly spotted Takuya Yamashiro,
Toei's live-action Spider-Man, in the mix.
We also see Spinneret and Spiderling,
Mangaverse Spider-Man from Earth-2301,
and a version of the Bombastic Bagman.
Curiously, the Spider-Man from the
Insomniac game universe appears not once,
but twice: one wearing his PS4 Advanced Suit,
and the other rocking the suit from "Marvel's
Spider-Man 2" for the PS5. And as expected,
many of these characters don't really
do anything significant in the film.
Meanwhile, the Spider-variants created
for "Across the Spider-Verse" include
Malala Windsor (aka Spider-UK of
Earth-835), Cyborg Spider-Woman,
and the Spidersona of Metro Boomin, who worked
on the "Across the Spider-Verse" soundtrack.